[laughter]
- Hey, Arturo, what's going
on with you and Ashley, man?
- Oh, yeah.
- She is dope, dude.
- Super hot, beautiful.
- Yeah, not so good, you know.
I think she might
be a little racist.
- What do you mean?
- Dude, she can't be racist.
She listens to
Pitbull by herself.
- Fine, she's always
complimenting me on my English.
- Hm.
- Not gonna lie to you, man.
Your English is on point, bro.
- Very good, very good English.
- I'm from Connecticut.
- But still, in spite of
that, your English is good.
- Anyways, you
think that's racist?
You know I'm dating
Hannah right?
- Oh my God, she's a bombshell!
- Unimpeachable.
- The essence.
- I feel like something's
sort of activated inside me.
- That's how I felt.
I understand where you all
are coming from originally.
But things have changed.
The other night, during sex,
she started calling
me Django, man.
[all together gasping]
- Django from the movie?
- Django the slave!
I was angry and
hard as a rock, man.
Unbreakable.
Then after that,
she started calling
herself Aunt Jemima.
- No!
- No, I'm saying no right there.
- That makes me uncomfortable.
- And then after all of that,
she made us both pancakes.
- Wow.
- Oh, I get it cause
she's in character now.
- I gotta commit to
the bit, you know.
God, get out.
- I was mad, right?
[together] Yeah.
- Couldn't even see
straight, I was so mad.
But the thing was about it,
them pancakes were
good, though, man.
[all laughing]
- Thank goodness.
- I don't know where
she's been with them.
- So what!
Slavery.
- Right.
- That is right.
- I think what I need to
do is break up with her.
- Smart move.
- I support you.
- Yeah, right after I
finish spending the next
three to six weeks
mastering that recipe!
[cheering]
- Breakfast, man.
Y'all can come over afterwards.
- So you wanna
hear about racism.
You guys know Jennifer?
- Is she still doing the..
- Rescuing orphaned dolphins.
[confirming together]
- Guys, stop!
Every time we hotel up, she
calls it a drone strike.
[gasps]
- Shit.
- She would take me outside,
lay a carpet on the floor,
call it a magic carpet,
say "Hey, Aladdin, why
don't you [censored],"
rubbed hummus on my [censored],
then she took a copy of
The Kite Runner and she
[censored]
She took a towel and [censored]
[muffled] I can't breathe.
She held me captive.
Twelve weeks.
- That's where you were.
- I thought you were
in Turks and Caicos.
- Rafi, she violated at least
five of the Geneva Conventions.
That was a hate crime.
- I know, I know.
But we do have the
same pant size!
I mean look at this.
[all exclaiming]
- Hand tailored Loft, yes.
- No, don't encourage that.
What are you going to do?
- I'm going to
break up with her,
after that winter
collection comes in
cause she got some
cool ass joggers!
- No!
Self respect, the lot of you!
- Alright, guess what,
you guys wanna hear about
some real, hardcore,
mean streets racism?
Well one time I went to
go see Maroon 5, right?
- Shut the fuck up!
- Alright, you wanna
hear some racist shit?
You ready?
So the other night right,
[Mexican Ballad]
- Is the agua clean yet, Juan?
- Not yet, but,
- Not yet, what?
- Not yet,
Senorita Ashley.
- What?
- No words, man
- Geez.
- I gotta break
up with her, man.
Even if she does have
laundry in her apartment.
So, I'm gonna go over
there, I'm gonna be strong.
I'm gonna look her
in the eye, okay,
and I'm just gonna tell her
from the bottom of my heart,
that we're gonna spend the
rest of our lives together!
[all cheering]
- Sorry, guys, but I think I
have to go clean my uniform!
[all together
chanting] Juan! Juan!
Juan Juan Juan Juan Juan!
Juan Juan Juan Juan Juan Juan!
- Oh man, dude we make the
best decisions at brunch.
- My husband is Asian like me.
[Guitar Strum]